the jurgen experience what's crazy is
when there's corruption but they'll
ignore it
because it'll it'll interfere with what
they want
right like this hunter biden [ __ ] yes
bro
it's crazy this was donald trump jr and
his hunter the one that passed away or
no no he's the one that's still alive
he's the one that took millions of
dollars did he marry the
the wife of the brother i hope so i
don't know something
something went wild there right didn't
someone go wild jamie
some went weird with the brother that
died's wife and hunter i
think i could be wrong don't quote me on
this
but the scandal is that he took a [ __ ]
ton of money
from russian billionaires right isn't
that the scandal jamie's
double googling right now hold what's
lit let's let's start with the brother
the wife of the bro i could be wrong
hunter biden
fathered child with woman while dating
brothers widow
whoa i mean this is a wild family can i
see a picture of this girl
good point she might have been hot as
well
joe biden is the one on the right okay
okay
hunter and haley biden they broke up
after nearly two years of dating
he filed she filed a paternity suit same
month hunter biden
49 married melissa cohen after just six
days of dating yeah well okay
maybe he found the perfect girl after
he'd already knocked up this other chick
and this other chick he [ __ ] hated
but he vowed to take care of the baby i
you know but essentially he's dating the
brothers that's interesting messy
sure people are messy sure listen the
brother's dead
maybe he's in love with the widow maybe
it's a perfect relationship sounds good
i don't have a problem with it right
i mean it's weird it is strange it's
certainly slacious odd it's
odd that biden is holding up children
and sniffing them that
that's not a sniffer but what
the other thing that bothers me is how
much did he get from
some billionaire he got money from a
russian billionaire i think was like
some
very large amount of money company
they're all involved in this energy
company they all find these little scams
that nobody knows about and then
eventually they come out like once every
four years election year
but i think a lot of them were working
for like the same energy company
in the ukraine that's involved with all
of these problems yeah well
i mean hillary clinton was involved with
the russians you know what's hilarious
there's one meme it's
a really good meme yeah here it is
hunter biden received 3.5 million wild
transfer from russian billionaire yeah
okay he was briefed about sons and biden
was briefed about sun's involvement
according to hunter biden's barista
hunter biden barisma what does that mean
okay scroll scroll back oh oh the
company's barista
hunter by joe biden's son hunter made
money from russia
china uh okay
all right um i don't know maybe he
earned the money
right now but i just know that it's
weird that the media is kind of ignoring
it well there's 100
in the tank they don't want trump
winning 90 of the media
episodes of the joe rogan experience are
now free on spotify
that's right they're free from september
1st to december 1st they're going to be
available everywhere but after december
1st they will only
be available on spotify but they will be
free
that includes the video the video will
also be there it'll also be free
that's all we're asking just go download
spotify much love